North Korea now says it will allow South
Korean reporters to witness the planned
dismantling of its nuclear test site
after it lashed out at over joint US
military drills with the South recently
about two dozen reporters from around
the world are being brought to North
Korea's only test site and CBS News is
the only u.s. broadcast network that is
in the group Ben Tracy is there and
reports from once on North Korea good
morning so our trip to the nuclear test
site was delayed by heavy rain in
northern North Korea so we've been here
in juan's on which is a city on the
country's east coast this city is famous
for one thing in particular a lot of
those missile tests you have seen video
of those happened here in wansun however
now North Korea is trying to make this
known for something else as you can see
this is absolutely stunning they're
trying to turn this into an
international tourist destination so
when you look down here in the distance
you see buildings under construction
that's going to be a massive resort you
see these blue shower pillars here on
the beach so someday they're hoping
millions of tourists from all over the
world will actually come here of course
before that happens they have to settle
this nuclear issue and that is part of
closing down this nuclear test site in
northern North Korea we are hoping that
we will get on a train will be headed 11
hours up towards that site North Korea
is going to put on what they're calling
a ceremony to officially decommission
that nuclear testing site for CBS this
morning Ben Tracy in once on North Korea
and Tracy thank you very much